you
yeah my name is Andy Hall I came from
Adobe Japan um I'm actually been a
couple of years since I gave us a
presentation in English but I'm sure
it's like falling off a bike so yeah and
my talk today is on server-side nodejs
programming with Photoshop so yeah
that's my self introduction I'm gonna
skip past it um this is a JavaScript
conference and obviously we all want to
talk about javascript so I know you're
all sitting there thinking why isn't
anybody talking about Photoshop yet well
finally the wait is over I'm gonna spend
the next 45 minutes like my Photoshop
but not really because actually I've not
I barely know how to use it cuz I'm a
programmer and I'm not a designer like a
like regarder said but it turns out for
various historical reasons Photoshop is
a tool that's been around like 25 years
it's if you're not familiar with it it
has to do with manipulating images but
for various historical reasons it's got
like three or four possibly five
different JavaScript interpreters built
into it for various sorts of
extensibility things and stuff like that
and there's a newest one that's just
come out about two months ago I think
it's based on node.js and that's what
I'm going to talk about there are
several things interpreters built-in for
various reasons one of them that I'm
going to focus on today is a there's a
VM called extend script and I think this
is back in the day when JavaScript well
you know it was only sort of half a
thing extended script has been in
Photoshop for ever and ever it's the way
you hook into all the Photoshop API is
if you want to like blur an image
there's a layer blur sort of API it's
the way that you create on Photoshop
extensions and I'm not going to go into
any detail on it at all but it leaves
somewhere in Photoshop and there's this
thing that you can access and there's
this layer on top of it called Kevlar
kfl like K of K V L R which is a kind of
a socket based interface and I'm not
gonna get into that stuff I'm gonna
gloss it over but there's several
different moving parts in there but what
has just recently shipped about two
months ago is that there's now an
instance of nodejs built into the
photoshop executable so anybody who's
running the current version there's an
odious someone their background and the
reason for that is it's purely as an
extensibility mechanism the idea is that
uh it's called generators the name of
the feature and the idea is that
underneath that instance of node there's
an app called generator core which is
built into Photoshop and runs
automatically and that app will load in
other nodejs apps and run them as float
as buggins
and that's what I want to talk about
today so the architecture I'll get to in
a minute
um first of all I want to show you what
the smart people at Adobe did with this
technology to show off it's sort of
reason for existing and this is my first
demo um when you start Photoshop if it's
the newest version it will have this
thing in the file menu called generate
image assets and the way it works is you
I'll just start up my trusty Photoshop
at this super maximum inhuman resolution
and and elope in a PSD and this is a PSD
that me the non designer made it's let's
just imagine for the sake of argument
that it's a website because this is
actually how websites mostly get made
like 95% of websites these days still
the designer lays it out in Photoshop
because there aren't that many good
design tools for HTML 5 which is
something we're working on but let's say
for the sake of argument got a designer
he's made this website in Photoshop and
usually everything is separated out on
layers and you've got all this like you
know the backgrounds a layer and
everything like that and then what
usually happens is he throws this at a
developer and the developer has to go
through and break out all the layers
into different pieces and apply styles
and then you know figure out the
architecture of the site based on the
design etc etc and um we don't have a
complete fix for that but one thing that
makes it a little easier is this
generator plug-in that comes like I said
built in and oh it's already turned on
so image assets is turned on and then
what you do is music amount so I can
maybe see the desktop as well I'll put
it like that so I've got a file browser
open on my desktop and inside this
Photoshop file I will take a like
foreground and this this is a layer name
is just the thing that design is used to
you know keep track of the assets I'll
make it layer name dot ping so
foreground ping and then over here in my
file browser next to the PSD a folder
has been made called SS and it's sort of
automatically generated this file called
photo or foreground dot ping which looks
like that
and then if I go back into Photoshop and
I let's say I want to get all designer
II and
like their I'm a designer look hey hey
so and the the image in the background
was updated live based on the way the
design works and the idea is that it
facilitates this whole process of
breaking your comp into little pieces
and putting all those pieces in the
website and that's that's great I mean
it's a really good I guess something for
designers it's not something that I use
in my work but going back to here
um the plus to this is that it's really
useful it solves people's problems and
in fact my colleague demoed this at an
ad agency and one of the people there
like literally cried I'm told so it's
really useful um but I have a big
problem with it because I'm a developer
engine evangelist and the problem is
this thing is it's just a useful thing
that makes people's lives better I don't
want that I want I want something that
you know looks like a crazy weird demo
and and serves no purpose so I made
something that looks like a crazy weird
demo and serves no purpose and that's
what I want to show you today um because
the point is that this thing that I just
showed I mean it publishes images but
it's not a feature to publish those
images the feature is that it's got this
whole extensibility layer and you can
sort of hook into it and do anything you
want so that's what I did so I will
close that and I'll make a new file and
make a recently sized file and now in
the background I will do something which
will I will explain in a moment in this
super super small resolution I will
okay I'll run this weird no js' command
and now something is running in the
background and and something has
happened and what has happened so far is
only one thing this file this is really
hard to deal with this resolution um
the file now has a new menu option
called awesome mode because it's awesome
that's why it's called awesome mode so I
turn that on and now some stuff is
happening in this node window and now
pay attention because this is what we're
about to see is I think basically the
future of Photoshop right I'm gonna zoom
in over here on the layer screen and
hopefully it'll work because I haven't
tried it in this room and sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't
okay Photoshop new layer see you do a
demo and it doesn't work what happens
all right what's going nuts
okay Photoshop okay photoshopped
okay Photoshop this is crazy
hold on okay Photoshop I've never had it
not work this well one okay Photoshop
why it does not work
okay this is really strange
okay Photoshop
I do not know why this would happen one
moment this is a nightmare
okay Photoshop
okay Photoshop Thanks new layer ah what
is it doing okay Photoshop this is
really crazy all right we're going to
change plans slightly I'm going to jump
into the code so I can make it not um I
can make it stop looking at those other
commands so let's pretend that demo
worked because it's clearly doing
something here what it's doing is it's
doing voice recognition and then in
theory that would have it would have
understood me saying okay Photoshop and
then it would have done like new layer
would make a new layer and random color
would make a cloud random color and
things like that so wow that was quite a
demo right so right really the guts are
working there's a some tuning to be done
possibly with acoustics but to move on
to the architecture so like I said
what's happening is inside Photoshop
there's this node application called
generator core that loads in and runs
other applications which are the plugins
the thing that I did in the terminal is
that you can also run over here on the
right side you can run your own instance
of node and then run in that instance a
separate copy of the generator core
application and then you can load in
separate plugins and the reason you can
do that is because like I said the
beginning there there was this
pre-existing sort of socket based
communication layer called Kevlar at the
top and both versions of generator core
hooked through that and that's why you
can have sort of multiple versions of it
but it's basically dev mode and you know
installed mode so if you're going to
roll out like I think my plugin as you
can see it's basically finished so if I
was going to roll that out to the world
they could put it inside their Photoshop
plugins directory and they wouldn't have
to run their own node command but when
you run it separately you can use a
different version a node or anything you
like so and that's why that command
happened um so moving out of the code I
will open a code editor this sum by the
way this is the decoded or I like best
at the moment is something called
brackets which is
this is um made internally at Adobe but
it's an open-source project and it's
it's an editor that's sort of
specialized for JavaScript and HTML and
CSS and it's actually made in JavaScript
and CSS as well so it's I think the only
editor where if you want to jump in and
change the code it's all HTML possibly
and I'll make it like super large for
this resolution yeah so and in here I'm
looking at the source of my awesome as
you can see it obviously awesome plugin
I'm inside here there is this is just a
regular node application as a
package.json and there's stuff in there
the only really important thing is to
declare a main function and you've got
one called main j/s and then inside main
j/s you've got you know a fairly normal
sort of looking node application if
you've ever used note this is what it
does and then down at the bottom
somewhere yeah all you really have to do
is export an init function and then
everything else is sort of handled by
this this core app that reads it in and
runs it for you apart from that it's a
completely normal vanilla node.js
application there's nothing magical
going on at all what happens inside the
stuff is well for example I've got a
package called Julius which I'll get to
in a second that's does the voice
recognition I've got some other stuff
and then in here somewhere in here there
is um various functions that do all the
things and if somewhere in here we see
yeah here's the the switch statement
that's doing all the commands and yeah
that's the really annoying part that's
causing all the trouble but getting that
back to them in a second okay now
pausing a moment I want to say a few
words about Julius which is the library
that I'm using for the voice recognition
because it's um it turns out to be kind
of interesting um usually if you were
going to try to put voice recognition
into an app with nodejs I think the
natural thing to do would to be using to
use an existing library that's what I
tried to do I couldn't find one they
worked very well because most of them
are based around the idea of piping
stuff out to an external service like
Google's speech detect service the
problem of that is that you tend to get
sort of get back anything so if you say
duplicate layer' you might get back the
text duplicate layer' but you might get
back lubricate player or whatever
because it's it's super generalized
Julius is a package that comes out of
Japan originally but all the stuff is
localized in English as well and it's a
sort of super generalized text on
recognition engine but you define your
own grammars and vocabularies and it
looks like this so inside the source you
define a piece of grammar that looks
like this where let's say like a
sentence can start with silence and then
do thank you and then silence ends or it
can be a PS command which is like layer
command layer for example and then in a
separate file you define a vocabulary
where you say like a layer command is
any of these three words and these three
words have these pronunciations and the
point of all this is and then it handles
all the magic of taking in an audio
stream and looking for these sounds but
the point of it is that it only knows
how to understand the commands that you
specifically define so if you if you
snap your fingers it will guess that it
is one of those commands that you've
chosen and that's why in theory I have
this very cleverly defined command chain
where you have to start by saying okay
Photoshop and then you do something else
because if you didn't have some kind of
trigger like that to start with
recognition then every noise would be
translated into like new layered or undo
or delete a layer or something like that
so um yeah so Julius is a it turned out
to be quite easy to work with and I
really recommend if you're doing
something that involves this kind of
thing in nodejs
it was really fun to get working uhm now
obviously this is great and going to
change the the face of Photoshop but
probably some of you have a nagging
question which is that wouldn't it you
know that wouldn't be kind of stupid if
everybody was like actually in a you
know design company with like 20 people
sitting in the same room using Photoshop
and they were all talking to their
machines wouldn't that be kind of stupid
the answer of it well obviously that
would be stupid because the Machine
wouldn't be answering them back right so
um the second feature of the demo and I
don't know if I can turn it on because
of this weird photo ok Photoshop stuff
the second feature is to have the
Photoshop answer back through this API
and let's probably more let's give it
some I'll rerun node and it's listening
over here again
I will turn awesome mode on again and do
I have audio okay
and we'll just keep this open and see if
it's working
okay Photoshop ok Photoshop voice mode
voice mode activated all right yeah
that's a big round of applause for a
very simple demo thank you very much I
appreciate that very very early so
that's obviously I'm like about five
lines of code in the node.js site
because all I'm doing is starting a
process and I'm handing it over text to
the speech or the say API which is
exists on Macintosh's and it looks like
I'll show you real quick there's yeah
function looks like this there's a it's
it's a it's using the spawn child method
of nodejs it's really simple you hand
over a line of text and it just works
and the great thing is if you run it on
a PC I don't know probably nothing
happens I've enjoyed it because it's a
demo yeah so alright moving on to
another architectural thing one of the
things that's interesting about working
with this kind of architecture is that
there are several different JavaScript
interpreters involved in this particular
case we have an ojs application which is
running inside you know vp8 is inside
there somewhere
you implement or running all the lines
of JavaScript somewhere inside Photoshop
there's a completely different VM
running a different it's not vp8 is
something much much older that's also
running JavaScript and when you want to
like make a new layer you've got to run
JavaScript you're in your node VM
running some script and you want to go
in to the Photoshop VM wherever the hell
that is and run some code that creates a
new layer and it turns out that it's
really really hard to get VMs to work
together like that and like share the
same namespace and so on but what's
really really easy is to pass text back
and forth so that's what actually
happens
in this architecture is that let's say
when I want to delete a layer first I
say I call this a function which has a
woman's voice saying deleting your layer
which is hilarious obviously and then I
call this function send yes and I pass
it an actual string of text which gets
sent over a socket into Photoshop and
somewhere inside that world this string
of Texas is a you know interpreted as
JavaScript and that would seem like a
really tedious way to work and it turns
out if you actually try it it is a
really tedious way to work so um the way
that I work around it and this is the
one and only JavaScript tip and
technique in my speech so enjoy it
um the way I work around that is that I
didn't know this if you pass a function
to the if you call to string on a
function it actually gives back the the
text definition of that function so if I
pass over a parenthesis and then a
function you know to string and then I
close the parentheses I pass in the args
the arguments and then I at the end yeah
I pass an open and close parenthesis
then it gets that text of that function
gets defined on the other side as an
iffy and instantly you know executed
with the arguments you pass over it's
kind of interesting and the reason I go
into that is because I think this kind
of thing is going we're going to see
more of it as the years go on um in fact
that's not even the only this isn't the
only time I've used that technique with
Photoshop in fact because um since a
couple of years ago we've started it in
Adobe at least we've started um having
all our come back we started doing quite
a lot of our sensibility stuff in html5
and for example like in Photoshop you
have yes and hunting and hunting and
hunting and hunting and hunting and
hunting and hunting okay
so apparently while I was talking
somehow I miraculously said okay
Photoshop okay um oh you know what in
fact the one thing I forgot to mention
um why is it keeps you're probably
wondering what the hell i enhance means
um that was a feature I put in because
I'm pretty sure this is gonna make a
million dollars I'm going to send this
to a Hollywood in fact the idea is if I
have a photo like this right and now
what I'll do first the cameras aren't
running it right the cameras aren't
running and I open this photo and I uh
oh I'm not in Photoshop and I'll pass it
a filter I'll do like a uh I'll do a a
box blur and then yeah so I'll box blur
like three times now I run the plug-in
and this is going to for this demo to
work this is going to have to another
America will have to occur it for me to
say okay Photoshop correctly but I'll
turn awesome mode back on right now you
run your cameras right in Hollywood and
the enhanced feature is just hooked into
the undo function and earlier I've
learned it three times so I say okay
Photoshop come on
okay Photoshop Photoshop
I really thought that was going to work
okay Photoshop Wow
come on one last time work okay okay
photos up
okay photos up okay put us up
okay photos up oh god this has never
failed listen well sorry
this actually has never failed in the
office it must be the I don't know max
anyway you say okay Photoshop then you
say enhance enhance enhance enhance
enhance that is the applause of pity but
I will take it alright so back to here
where were we oh yeah oh and so the
reason I think we'll see more of this is
that four so Photoshop for example um
you can define your own panels in
Photoshop and then you can package them
up as extensions and you can sell them
to people and stuff like that and they
can inside that panel you can you know
define your own workflows or whatever
you want to do but when if you define
your own panel the the code that you
would define the panel in is html5 I'm
echoing really sorry about that and and
so that features actually been in
Photoshop for about two years I think
and the way it works is there's a little
implementation of chromium like the
chromium embedded framework and so each
panel that you define html5 it has a
little instance of Chrome thank you very
much Google for making a chromium
embedded framework free and then so that
kind of extensibility is already made in
html5 in in that case if you want to run
illegally or something it's the same
thing you have to pass a string of
JavaScript over to the other VM and I
think it's so easy and it makes so much
sense to embed like many web views
inside applications that I think we'll
see more and more applications taking
that route and then that'll mean in more
and more cases you'll need to be passing
strings of JavaScript between different
VMs because it makes so much sense to to
put in different viens for different
reasons and it's so very difficult to
get them to share the same context but
anyway
I'm moving back to this Beach so there's
a quick digression now which is um my
dream is I have a lot of books at home
my dream is that someday there could be
some kind of like nodejs that plugs into
my living room and then I could call a
function that would sort the books in
like a certain order so they could sort
be sorted by like color or by subject or
some like that and this I think goes
sort of to Tim's talk this morning about
the Internet of Things I mean if you
could do that just think what you do you
you would you spend all day hacking the
living room I mean it'd be so you know
bloody useful that you you wouldn't want
to do anything else but the reason I go
into this is that when you have a tool
like Photoshop and this is true of like
a lot of 3d tools a lot of video tools a
lot of like layout tools for like
digital publishing that kind of stuff
any time a tool like a design tool or a
production tool gets to a suitable level
of complexity then across the world
there's going to be tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousand people who's sort
of their job is to use that tool for
eight hours a day and that's all they do
and that I mean that's certainly true of
Photoshop in the world it's like ad
agencies there's all they'll have them
dozens of people who do that kind of
work but when you take something like
nodejs it's that powerful and has that
many existing libraries and you plug it
in to a tool that's that sort of deep
and heavily used it it sort of achieves
the same thing as if you could plug
nodejs into your living room because
that I mean the the Photoshop UI that's
to those tens of thousands of people
that's their living room that's where
they spend all their time and so now if
you if they have a way to like I'm gonna
write some JavaScript you know my my PSD
has ten thousand layers and it's really
you know hard to manage them so I'm
gonna write a script that's going to
filter them or or whatever is necessary
maybe not for everybody but for me my
personal workflow you know it's sort of
for that person it's as handy as being
able to sort your bookshelves and that's
why I think the sort of thing is going
to happen a lot more um in Adobe it's
strictly a sort of early stage
experiment I mean it's it's a fully
supported feature but whether we're
going to keep doing this in every other
app we make is something that I don't
know yet but certainly it's um the idea
of putting a node instance in the
Photoshop and being able to extend it
it's I think it's something that we see
it as a big success and it's something
that we really want to to roll out in
other applications and also the thing
that I mentioned before about defining
panels in html5 that's I think
about seven of our applications now like
flash illustrator and design a couple
more they all share the same sort of
mechanism for defining a panel in html5
so this sort of not nothing to do with
web browsers at all but defining stuff
in in html5 and JavaScript and using
that to extend tools that are
pre-existing I think is certainly
something working and continue and I
hope it bleeds over into other like I'm
3d apps and things like that
and
yeah so um leaving that there I have one
more gratuitous demo and this is another
thing that also makes no sense and also
here's the fun part
um may not work because it really is
sensitive to the way the the room is
designed in the way the lighting works
but and I'm keeping a secret even though
it's sitting on the screen right now
because it says leap so has anybody
tried leap motion these are these things
here dude yeah alright well you see what
it is in a second um I thought wouldn't
it be awesome and completely useless to
hook leaked motion into Photoshop and
the great part is I don't have to speak
to turn it on it's just gonna so in
theory it could in theory work might not
so I've run my node again now I have my
application open I will make a new layer
now I've plugged in my leap motion now
in principle
you know what I need to turn on awesome
mode
there we go
here we go
yeah
alright okay so and apparently I have
some debug code to there in there as
well so yeah what's that doing um leap
motion for those of you haven't worked
with it yet it's a little device that
measures that track some space above
your above little device like that for
things like gestures and thing and
things like that it was really really
easy to work with and I really recommend
if you want to play with it in getting
one it's about a hundred dollars I think
in the u.s. in yourselves and the code
to access it winds up being very simple
and very well-documented and every
problem that I had with it turned out to
be due to the fact that it has just had
a big update and it the documentation
hasn't reflected anything that changed
so the big key to where is this it
turned out that the big secret to
working well with leach is was to use
the node leap jsm controller library and
to downgrade it to before the recent
update and I'm sure there's lots of
great stuff in the new update but it
isn't documented so I couldn't get it to
work but then what you wind up doing
inside leap J yes it has it communicates
over a socket but the the socket handler
is is very well done in it it handles
all its own code so all you really need
to do is make a listener and stuff and
then every couple of will every however
often you specify you get a frame and
then it hands you information about
things like whether that frame has some
fingers and how many fingers it has and
then if they're valid or not and then
you sort of parse through this code and
so all I'm doing here is I'm tracking
the fingers and then normally I draw a
couple of guidelines to show you where
your fingers it are and then if and then
when the you get back a 3d pointer the
the third number in the in the the 3d
pointer data is a Z and the Z is in this
case this access so all I'm doing is the
Z equals one is the access of the device
so every time Z goes past one I call it
touching and then I start drawing the
line and it's quite simple and this code
is up on github and I'll show you in a
second
and so it wound up this is I don't know
if you took out the comments this is
like 20 lines just to get that working
so now having said that is it a good way
to draw lines no it's a really really
terrible way to draw lines because it's
it's not that fast and the tracking is
not very accurate and if you actually do
it well first of all if you have like a
reflective ceiling but nothing will
happen because it completely fails and
then if you actually try to draw it
it'll randomly sort of decide whether
your thumb is a finger or not and and
the data will keep fluctuating it's
really really hard to use but my point
in sort of implementing this is that if
you can do that you can sort of do
anything so smarter Minds than mine can
in theory take this technology and and
make things that actually do make sense
like for example if you um if you're an
ad agency and you have a couple of
hundred people who use Photoshop every
day you probably also have some kind of
CMS where you stall your assets you
probably have some kind of workflow that
requires people to submit designs to
their boss and their boss to submit
those designs to a client and if you
have no js' built into the tools you
could in principle you could not only
say hook in you know no photoshop
directly into the CMS or the that offers
a some process or what do you everyone
do you could mean scrap that ID you
could run the CMS from inside Photoshop
if you wanted to because it's not you
can do anything you could make a sort of
get file you know you know decentralized
sort of process where everybody has
their own repository that lives inside
Photoshop and you could we I mean the
the possibilities are kind of endless
because it's node and you can anything
that there's all these thousands of
great libraries for node and you can now
call them all from Photoshop and you can
call Photoshop from them so I think it's
an example of taking two really deep
complex things and hooking them together
and hopefully you sort of multiply the
the possibilities of what comes out
that's essentially all my talk I've
smoked really fast and I have some time
left the source is online oh I should
have mentioned everything except
Photoshop that I showed is open source
and on github so the generator core the
app that loads in and runs the plugins
is open source the the built-in plugin
for publishing out the the image assets
that's also on github and it's all there
it's for people to extend and
and do something with my my source is
also up I wouldn't necessarily recommend
you go off it but there are some better
getting started sort of plugins if you
want to give it a try and I will there
was a bunch of links in here and so I
put the slides up a moment ago and I
will just tweet that so if anybody wants
to the slides that I just tweeted them
and they're up there somewhere and and
that's my Twitter and that's my talk so
and we have actually a bunch of time for
questions if anybody has any thank you
very much